you're the best Alan Rickman story I've
heard is he used to go out for dinner
with friends all the time and they would
try to pay and he'd say I got this Harry
Potter he was just paper meals and stuff
you know um so I really want to start
with a sincere congratulations this
movie is looking awesome tried to bleep
myself
um it's the fastest two and a half hour
movie I've seen in a long time I want to
specifically talk about the fact that
what you not only were you cast in the
movie and the thing is sometimes when
you wear cast you can have a small role
and it's still cool but what was it like
for you getting cast and then you know
Tom and Chris are like
yeah you have a massive role you're
involved in all the action can you do
this or get ready yes well yeah uh it
was a lot in that uh for context you
know when I came in to do the screen
test uh McCue had seen me in the play 10
years previously and he was like I wanna
what you do on that stage I want to
bottle it and put it onto the screen and
write a character for you but I don't
know what that is yet we cut to 10 years
later and he calls me up and he says
will you come in and read with Tom we're
thinking of creating uh the next
installment of Mission Impossible
looking for a new Leading Lady opposite
him and there wasn't a character that I
had to fit into there was just this
brief of going Let's see we want to find
the actress who loves this work
um ethic who loves the process of it he
loves to collaborate and throw herself
into every opportunity with all these
resources and working with these experts
as is possible and from that a character
is going to emerge and so it was this
sense that you can sort of on a daily
basis basis write yourself into the
story or if you become back-footed or a
bit fearful or a bit kind of like ah you
you um You Take Your Eye Off The Off the
Mark you could also backtrack out of the
movie like there was this kind of a
strong sense of that that's how
collaborative it felt like so I came in
going we don't know who this character
is but she didn't have a name for a long
time
um but I will try lots of different
things and we're going to see what lands
and we're gonna see what the film wants
I'm gonna see what the camera wants and
ultimately what the audience wants so
here you have Grace yeah and also the
other thing about this franchise is
Chris is so good at writing great female
characters you know
um so man I have a ton of questions
let's talk about the car chase in Rome
just because it's so incredible and
unique because it adds humor that feels
earned not just forced to make people
laugh yes so talk a little bit about
filming that sequence because you also
shot during the day in Rome streets are
shut down crazy yeah it's okay crazy
you're absolutely right you know
Macquarie is an incredible writer he
really understands structure and
professor and pressure and how to put
characters together in a situation that
they they shouldn't be in or don't want
to be in and that has inherent tension
to it and so the comedic elements to
that are sort of comic relief and in
between those moments of um how high the
stakes are but nothing that feels too as
you said too pushed too forced to
reached for every time we tried
something that felt farcical or felt a
little bit
um too cute it didn't work and we could
feel it and we could change and pivot
and to do something else but a lot of
the humor came out of the kind of
natural circumstance of Ethan Hunt being
undermined by Fiat 500 I mean that in
itself is so brilliant you know the car
became a character in and of itself and
so to have Grace who's an outsider not
knowing who Ethan Hunt is watching a man
instead of turning on the engine turning
on the windscreen wipers so she's she's
a bit worried for him and she's also
kind of worried myself that she's she's
not with someone who really knows what
they're doing and so there was a kind of
um
an ease with finding the comedy between
us I think that came out of the
circumstances what I love about Tom is
that he's willing to look stupid on
camera and there's a shot in that
sequence where he's just almost giving
up like I don't unders like you know and
it's many actors would not give that
shot but Tom you know what I mean I
completely I'm so pleased you picked up
on that because
um
you could see that every day he leaves
his his ego and his pride at the door
and he is able to seed power it for the
sake of a great moment in the movie
um or something new that we haven't seen
him do as Ethan Hunt and to watch him
or find the kind of the vulnerabilities
and the the slightly more you know
idiosyncratic version of Ethan who feels
a little embarrassed or humiliated and
he really leaned into that and the the
funnier it becomes and the more we like
him and so he's just he's masterful at
knowing what the audience wants one of
the other things to know about taking
this role because you're in both parts
is this has been filming for basically
20 years and it's going to continue
filming through the beginning of next
year again I don't know how much of a
role you have in part two but was it was
there any hesitation taking a role that
would require years of your life maybe
you didn't know at the time you know
like talk a little bit about that aspect
yeah we we didn't know I mean I think
with something with the ambition that
they had for this it was It was kind of
obvious to me that this probably would
run over a little bit
um the training alone before we began
shooting was five months and so the the
you also get the sense that are not
going to stop until it's right they are
so dedicated to
um delivering a film for the audience it
truly Delights them and surprises them
from the last installment so when you're
there you understand why things take as
long as they take you understand the
level of detail that goes into it from
every department and also changes that
they're making on the day when they come
up with a better idea or they go you
know what that we thought that idea
delivered but actually we've come up
with something that's far more
interesting and that has been naturally
born out of a sudden change in location
or something that I did that suddenly
went you know what let's actually have
her in this in this moment take a left
instead of a right
um and I love working in that way
because it feels very alive you know if
this is had been a script that we shot
to the book every single day that didn't
change that was the same then that's a
that takes a different kind of level of
patience but just the sheer variety of
what I was asked to do and had access to
learning was so uncomfortable
encompassing that it's you know far
beyond the film it's it's really changed
my life yeah also there's very few
filmmakers who can do what Chris and Tom
do without a script it's it's Madness
what they can pull off yeah you know
it's unbelievable yeah I gotta go um uh
enjoy those through speed dating and
seriously congrats